hermit Dylan is obviously a famous civil
rights attorney she's highly familiar
with this case and we have to ask why
did a judge allow cameras into the court
to take pictures of trump normally you
see sketches
that seemed like part of a strategy a
political strategy not a legal one Army
Dylan thank you for coming on what did
you make of that
well I agree with you Tucker I mean if
the Democratic party is using this
prosecution which I believe they are to
influence the outcome of the next
election this photograph is going to be
a prop in those campaign ads and it all
seems to be you know really well
targeted towards that I would even say
that the judge not putting a gag order
on both sides in this case is the same
because by by scolding the defendant and
saying you better stay away from an
imaginary line that I'm not going to
draw for you he's effectively chilling
his speech while at the same time not
putting any constraints whatsoever on
the district attorney who could go out
and in fact completely ignore his his uh
his oath to do justice and prejudge that
the defendant is already guilty he said
that multiple times in his remarks while
winking and at the same time admitting
that he didn't even have to articulate
what the charges are so this entire
proceeding seems to be clearly rigged in
a political Manner and somewhere along
the way Way Tucker Americans may have
not noticed that the Democratic party
has basically turned into a gang of
thugs there is no concept of due process
there is no concept of even with a
straight face attempting to tie the
charges to something that you can prove
in front of a court of law that could
stand up on appeal and so if there were
ever any more evidence than than we
already suspected I think the way that
today's proceedings went really
underscores the political nature of this
and if I were to make a comment about
the president's remarks today I would
say that what was missing from that is
pointing out that this indictment is
really aimed at the American people it's
aimed at president Trump's supporters
it's aimed at terrorizing people away
from supporting a particular candidate
and it is meant to remind all of us that
if they can do this to a former
president they can concoct false charges
with without even articulating what the
charges are against any American for
political reasons and that is a form of
emotional terrorism I'm talking should
really be terrifying to all Americans
that this is the current state of the
law in New York City
he should say that in every public
appearance going forward I agree with
that hermitone thank you so much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight